je ne crains c'est ukrainienne armés
jusqu'aux dents annonce qu'elle son rôle
un discours aux accents nationalistes et
au ton déterminé
olena below the kite et heroes delhi
puis officiel de la marine et des taux
jour d'hui lieutenante des forces armées
ukrainiennes elle nous parle depuis un
bon quart à kiev the
avengers the bomb
dans son bataillon la lieutenante olena
n'est pas la seule femme
campagnes informent à de forts
après plus de 10 jours de combats olena
dit qu'elle est très fatigué ne dort que
deux heures par nuit
sur la toile les femmes d'ukrainiens qui
rejoignent l'armée sont légion
une tradition qui remonte à la seconde
guerre mondiale dans l'union soviétique
où plus de 800 mille femmes se sont
engagés dans l'armée rouge certains
partis les craintes sont maintenant en
guerre depuis 2014 donc les femmes ont
tout doucement appris à se mettre dans
la tête qu'ils allaient peut-être avoir
un conflit et que peut-être elle devrait
apprendre à manier les armes y en a
certaines qui était déjà parti justement
dans le donbass pour se battre à côté
des hommes
avant l'offensive russe l'armée
ukrainienne comptait 17 % de femmes
et lorsqu'il ne porte pas les armes des
ukrainiennes s'activent pour acheminer
l'aide et la nourriture aux soldats les
femmes dans un conflit dont un rôle
actif quelle
université drôle que souvent on ne
comprend pas est ce que ça veut dire
aussi alors que la paix sera fait qu'il
faut impliquer les femmes dans le
processus de paix aussi parce qu'elles
ont justement jouer un rôle et que elles
aussi veulent décider peut-être du futur
de leur pays
en cette journée internationale des
droits des femmes
des appels à la paix ont résonné même à
saint-pétersbourg en russie
et pour la lieutenante olena ce combat
demeure celui de la liberté glee du
green ce nom mais de fin de
nuit à des fins de zéro c'est le monde
ici à cenon khayat radio canada montréal